à écouter bonjour à vous tous d'abord je
suis vraiment heureuse heureuse de faire
comme d'habitude cette rentrée avec vous
je m'entends vous dire que dans
l'ambiance actuelle ça fait du bien de
voir des jeunes qui ont envie d'agir de
construire leur avenir qui ne sont pas
en permanence les yeux dans le
rétroviseur
parce que en fait en matière d'avenir
la rentrée des socialistes l'exécutif
c'est plutôt retour vers le passé
ils regrettent sans arrêt leurs paroles
leurs actions allaient j'allais dire
leur mission mais c'est encore autre
chose
bref leur comportement d'ailleurs
regardez à la rochelle il ya quelques
jours je vais regarder un peu les images
et vous avez écouté un peu à écouter
tous ceux qui l'ont fait ont pu
constater que les valeurs de la gauche
était soluble dans la sueur du premier
ministre vas y et la chemise qui n'a pas
hésité au milieu de ses adversaires
pardon de ses partisans à brader ce qui
restait des thèmes de campagne de
françois hollande en 2012
et c'est sans arrêt de macron à taubira
en passant par aides s'amène vidalis où
les autres lors qu'istres
gouvernementale nous jouons maintenant
depuis des semaines une cacophonie
assourdissante et françois hollande ans
hollande me direz vous la seule chose
sur laquelle il ne se contredit pas
c'est qu'il est content content de lui
mais si je vous assure
allez on n'est pas là pour parler d'eux
on ma toujours expliqué considéré qu on
ne tirait pas sur une ambulance
alors parlons de choses plus
intéressantes
parlons de vous parlons de nous parlons
de l'avenir
parlons de la france vous le savez vous
les jeunes en particulier la politique
ne doit plus être perçu comme un système
qui est réservé à une élite comme des
gens qui sont entre eux qui parlent
d'eux et qu'ils ne s'intéressent qu'à
eux
bien loin des préoccupations du plus
grand nombre
c'est ça le vrai problème de la
politique aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les français ont
l'impression que c'est une petite caste
qui fait de la politique que eux n'ont
plus prise sur les décisions de son
prise ni même sur les analyses qui sont
faites les gens ont l'impression qu'on
ne sait pas ce qu'ils vivent qu'on ne
connaît pas leur problème est qu'on ne
répond pas à leurs attentes
et bien moi je vous le dis parce que ç'a
toujours été ma conviction depuis le rpr
à travers tout ce que nous avons été je
suis convaincu d'une chose c'est que la
politique ne peut pas être le seul fait
du marketing et de la communication
emporté par le règne des petits coups
que l'on va faire ça n'est pas une
chemise sans cravate encore que je vous
félicite les jeunes de pouvoir cravate
mais c'est pas une chemise sans cravate
une barbe de trois jours où un déjeuner
chez des français qui vont régler les
questions de l'immigration de l'emploi
du terrorisme de la compétitivité de
notre agriculture ou de nos industries
oui
alors si on parle de mode ya une mode en
ce moment qui m'étonne un peu chez les
politiques
ils ont tout changé françois hollande a
changé que pal ça change et il change
tous les uns des autres
côté croyez sans ma petite expérience
les hommes sont ce qu'il ya de plus
difficile à changer et plus ils
vieillissent et plus le cas à force de
changer leur look pour faire croire
qu'ils ont changé d'état d'esprit
je crois que trop de responsables
politiques ne voient plus que c'est le
monde qui change autour d'eux le monde
mais aussi l'europe mais aussi la france
et surtout les français ils ne voient
plus les problèmes politiques du moment
ce qui préoccupe vraiment nos
concitoyens il n'anticipe pas les
problèmes de demain
finalement il ne voit qu'eux eh bien
vous vous qui avez les yeux ouverts vous
les voyez vous voyez vous les problèmes
des français vous voyez comment les
français vivent ce qu'ils attendent
vous voyez ce qui se passe et ce qui se
passe chers amis c'est que la france ne
va pas bien à l'extérieur
son image est dégradée par trop de
velléités trop de renoncement à
l'intérieur sa cohésion est menacé par
des discours du gouvernement qui monte
les français les uns contre les autres
son dynamisme est entamée parce que nos
concitoyens se demande vers quel avenir
on les mène par ce qui est parce que
ceux qui ont envie de travailler sont
découragés de le faire parce que chacun
se demande quelles sont ses perspectives
quelles sont les perspectives de ses
enfants vous le savez je suis gaulliste
comme un certain nombre d'entre vous ici
je le suis par respect pour l'homme de
la france libre
par attachement à la personnalité du
général de gaulle mais je suis également
gaulliste parce que convaincu que le
gaullisme et la réponse politique
moderne et adapté aujourd'hui aux
problématiques de ce monde qui ment qui
bouge je suis je suis peut-être est
avant tout sans doute gaulliste pour cet
engagement si singulier qu'elle le
pragmatisme politique qui s'inscrit
comme une belle paire native à la fois
l'ultra libéralisme et au socialisme aux
communistes
de l'autre côté oui je pense que le bon
sens que la recherche de solutions
pragmatiques concrètes que la
perspective en maintenant la réflexion
sur ce qui est en train de se passer sur
ce qui va se passer c'est la solution
pour permettre à notre pays qui est un
grand pays qui a toujours été un grand
pays de continuer à jouer les leaders de
développer la richesse qui est en lui de
permettre à chacune et à chacun de
réussir de progresser
quand on veut agir quand on veut réussir
on le peut à une condition c'est de ne
pas rêver c'est d'être au contraire les
deux pieds dans la réalité de bien voir
ce qui est possible ce qui est utile et
ce qu'il faut éviter
mais la première chose et le pragmatisme
en politique c'est d'abord ça c'est de
dire ses devoirs c'est de ne pas se
cacher la vérité aujourd'hui bien de nos
compatriotes bien de ceux qui vous
entourent dans vos familles chez vos
amis sont dans le doute sont dans la
crainte sont dans l'angoissé du
lendemain
ils sont persuadés qu'on leur ment que
les journalistes leur mentent que les
politiques leur ment
et qu'en même temps on ignore la réalité
de leurs problèmes quotidiens
ils ont l'impression qu'on ne parle
jamais de ce qu'il veut ce qu'ils vivent
ils ont l'impression qu'il y a des mots
tabous et qu'on ignore ce que pense que
l'on méprise ceux qui peuvent dire
alors oui je vous le dis pourquoi le
nier
écoutez autour de vous vous allez vous
en rendre compte les français ont peur
peur de demain peur du monde qui se
construit sous leurs yeux
sous leurs yeux mais sans eux ils ont
peur pour eux pour leur avenir
mais ils ont peur aussi pour leurs
enfants
alors bien sûr je sais quand on prononce
le mot peur immédiatement on accuse de
ça c'est sûr les voix des extrêmes et
bien les commentateurs les donneurs de
leçons ferait mieux d'écouter les
français parce que eux utilise ce mot au
quotidien oh certes pas les français des
cercles de pouvoir
pas les français des dîners en ville de
l'élite politique ou médiatique
non les français de nos campagnes de nos
villes de nos bords de mer comme des
plateaux aveyronnais ou du massif
central
oui les français ont peur ils ont peur
pour leur sécurité au quotidien
et quand je parle de sécurité c'est pas
l'insécurité dans le sens banal ils ont
peur pour la sécurité de leur emploi ils
ont peur pour la sécurité de leur
retraite ces retraites si
merveilleusement gérées par les
socialistes que les caisses de retraites
s'interroge sur la capacité à maintenir
les versements même niveau les français
ont peur pour leur sécurité dans les
transports ferroviaires et nos candidats
aux élections régionales savent combien
ce problème est épineux
ils ont peur des transports aériens et
en particulier depuis le crash de l'af
zaman ring ils ont peur pour dans le
transport routier alors que nous nous
avions inversé
la courbe de la mortalité en voiture les
français ont peur pour leur sécurité
environnementale pour leur sécurité
alimentaire
et quoi de plus logique après le
scandale de l'aval de la vache de ceux
de la viande de cheval dans les lasagnes
et alors qu à longueur d'émissions
télévisées on nous explique les recettes
de la malbouffe
oui les résultats sont là les français
ont peur mais ceci dit reconnaître une
vérité ça ne suffit pas et je vous le
dis en particulier à vous les jeunes ça
ne suffira jamais c'est bien de dire la
vérité
mais ensuite il faut aussi proposer
quelque chose on n'a pas le droit
quand on est un responsable politique de
surfer sur la peur on doit la combattre
et on doit la combattre avec des mesures
pragmatiques
on ne doit pas la combattre par la
démagogie on doit le combattre par le
réalisme par le bon sens par le
pragmatisme
sans sympa ici mais en même pas prévu un
verre d'eau bon mais on va s'en passer
oui chers amis si les français ont peur
notre devoir notre obligation c'est de
les assurer par nos actes et la
meilleure façon de le faire c'est
d'abord de garantir leur sécurité
pas la sécurité mais les sécurité dont
je viens de parler et pour la sécurité
des biens et des personnes
il est évident que nous devons rappeler
que la première des libertés sa demeure
de pouvoir vivre paisiblement de pouvoir
sortir le soir de pouvoir aller retirer
de l'argent à la banque
sans crainte d'être menacée et là la
réponse à l'essai elle éclaire la
tolérance zéro en matière de crimes et
de délits doit être la règle
l'accélération des procédures pénales
doit être la préoccupation majeure
ça ne sert à rien d'avoir une
condamnation quand on en a une
cinq ans après
la réelle l'exécution des peines doit
être l'obligation prioritaire on ne peut
pas continuer à voir 80 mille peines et
avec les siennes taubira je pense que ça
peut représenter d'ailleurs maintenant
qu'ils ne sont pas exécutées
c'est pas simplement un problème de
justice s'est passablement un problème
de réponse aux victimes
c'est tout simplement un problème
d'exemplarité
si on veut dissuader il faut que les
gens soient sûrs d'être punis s'ils
enfreignent la loi
et puis c'est vrai il ya des choses
nouvelles ces dernières années
ce terrorisme et moi j'ai bien connu les
problèmes du terrorisme comme ministre
de la défense
c'était le début avec l'afghanistan
comme ministre de l'intérieur comme
ministre de la justice comme ministre
des affaires étrangères et le terrorisme
je les ai vus monter et prendre génial
on y arrive voyez vous permettez je me
tourne à cause des photos et bien en la
matière il faut savoir une chose c'est
que personne n'est à l'abri personne
n'est à l'abri parce que dans les
nouvelles formes de terrorisme on
utilise beaucoup les réseaux sociaux et
qu'à côté des réseaux que notre police
notre gendarmerie
nos services spéciaux arrive assez bien
à suivre il y à aussi tousser recruter
individuelles isolées et qui sont
capables en se laissant endoctrinés
ensuite de vouloir agir
c'est pour ça qu'il est très difficile
de lutter contre cette forme de
terrorisme et qu'il est qu'il est
irresponsable de dire qu' il n'y aura
pas un jour une personne menacée par le
terrorisme mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut baisser les bras et la france
a en la matière
un rôle prioritaire à jouer un rôle
prioritaire parce que d'abord elle est
l'un des pays les plus menacés que
deuxièmement elle a une expérience
qu'elle a un savoir faire dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et qu'elle a une
volonté politique et une vision qui
était une vision mondiale kim il faut le
reconnaître
manque un certain nombre de pays alors
oui la france doit faire le nécessaire
pour agir énergiquement contre des chais
contre toutes ces villes ses filiales
d'aqmi et autres dans le monde
elle doit le faire sur son territoire
bien entendu mais elle doit aussi le
faire à la source
là où ces réseaux puisent leur force
leurs ressources leur camp
d'entraînement
et puis la france doit agir non pas seul
mais en entraînant les autres pays les
autres pays européens et les autres pays
qui sont contre l'extrémisme dans la
lutte contre l'intégrisme est là aussi
en travaillant sur les causes de cet
intégrisme chez elle mais également
partout autour du globe
à défaut il faut être conscient d'une
chose c'est que la vague des demandeurs
d'asile sera de plus en plus grande
moi je constate bien que en europe il ya
trois jours ou même dans notre pays on
semble découvrir aujourd'hui c'est vague
de migrants il ya quatre ans que j'ai
écrit que compte tenu de la
multiplication des conflits dans le
monde après la fin de la guerre froide
où les socialistes se croyait qu'on
allait pouvoir toucher les dividendes de
la paix avec toutes les tensions qui
sont en train de se révéler il y aurait
de plus en plus de gens qui
chercheraient tout simplement à fuir la
mort à fuir les crimes exercée contre
eux et qui viendrait dans les endroits
calmes
c'est à dire d'abord en europe parce que
c'est le plus proche
et donc il est évident que l'on aurait
dû anticiper là-dessus et c'est vrai
pour l'europe c'est vrai pour chacun des
pays
alors aujourd'hui nous avons
effectivement un problème mais dont nous
devons savoir que c'est pas simplement
le problème d'aujourd'hui mais que c est
que ce sera de plus en plus le problème
de demain si nous n'allons pas agir sur
les causes c'est à dire on met enfin un
certain nombre de conflits ou en
arrêtant les massacres qui sont commis
contre les chrétiens d'orient ou contre
un certain nombre de peuples
il faut agir avec détermination contre
ses causes et il faut essayer d'éviter
les amalgames
le problème des migrations ne supporte
ni les à peu près neige lundi stick ni
les anathèmes et encore moins la
démagogie il y a des différences entre
les demandeurs d'asile et les migrants
économiques
les exilés fui la guerre et la terreur
il demande un accueil temporaire dans un
pays et la spire qui à retourner chez
eux ce ne sont pas des migrants
économiques
ils ne peuvent donc pas être traitées
selon les mêmes critères
mais il y a un problème général parce
qu'il ya un problème de différences de
niveau de vie dans le monde et que vous
aurez toujours des gens qui espérons
trouver une vie meilleure sur le
territoire européen
alors en matière de migration si
l'europe veut une réponse coordonnée
homogène efficace elle se doit déjà de
faire des choses très pragmatique de bon
sens c'est dans toute l'europe
appliquer les mêmes règles les mêmes
aides et aussi les mêmes actions pour
renvoyer les illégaux dans leur pays
sinon quand vous avez un pays qui
apparaît plus généreux où tu laxiste que
les autres eh bien il se précipite tout
cela et comme effectivement l'europe est
un espace dans lequel on circule eh bien
ils finissent quelle que soit leur point
d'entrée dans le pays qui apparaît comme
le plus généreux entre guillemets et
c'est le cas en particulier pour la
france
la france sait ils font même être
conscient
une source d'attraction privilégié pour
ceux qui ne recherchent que des
avantages et qui ne veulent pas donner
en échange
eh bien nous devons contrôler très
explicitement ça et il faut mettre fin à
ce système qui fait qu'on ne reconduit
quasiment jamais
un immigrant illégal dans son pays
ou en tous les cas à l'extérieur de nos
frontières c'est ça le problème
parce que là aussi quand les gens feront
qu ils peuvent venir mais que s'ils ne
sont pas en situation régulière ils ont
toutes les chances d'être reconduit ça
freinera aussi des choses et bien
entendu nous devons dans le même temps
agir dans les pays d'origine pour
essayer de permettre aux gens d'y avoir
une vie décente
parce que sinon ce n'est pas à l'arrivée
avec des gens qui viennent de partout
qu'on pourra régler le problème
oui dans ce domaine aussi c'est à la
france de montrer le chemin
c'est à nous de dire ce qu'il faut faire
et nous devons continuer et sur le reste
dont je parlais tout à l'heure cette
santé environnementale sanitaire
alimentaire cela exige des réponses
qu'ils soient pas des réponses
historique des réponses plus verte que
verte ou je ne sais trop quelle couleur
les réponses doivent être pragmatique
elles doivent être adaptées elles
doivent être partagés par les français
et là aussi il faut savoir que le bon
sens est souvent plus efficace que les
règlements tatillon rien ne sert de
multiplier chez nous en france des
normes contraignantes
quand les produits de nos voisins
européens qui ne sont pas soumis aux
mêmes contraintes
parce que les règles européennes sont
souvent plus large que les règles
françaises
et bien quand ces produits et ça à nos
exigences et sont consommés chez nous
puisqu'il y rentrer librement
ça aussi c'est du bon sens en france
notre administration veut toujours laver
plus blanc que blanc
alors en europe ont fait d'énormes pour
essayer que ceux qui sont le plus en
retard nous rejoignent ce qui est
important à la fois pour notre sécurité
et pour la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
mais si à chaque fois l'administration
et le gouvernement en remet une couche
de contraintes supplémentaires eh bien
nous n'aurons jamais une europe avec une
vraie égalité de concurrence entre les
entreprises européennes
et puis et puis reid évident quand on
parle de sécurité que je ne peux pas ne
pas évoquer les problèmes de l'emploi la
sécurité de l'emploi qui est devenu la
préoccupation majeure des français et
surtout le symbole de l'échec du
gouvernement et des mensonges de
françois hollande
le pragmatisme le bon sens à la matière
c'est de rappeler que ce sont bien les
entreprises qui créent l'emploi avec un
gouvernement
inconsciente elle que le nôtre qui fait
peser de telles charges de tels honneurs
bien plus que dans tous les autres pays
d'europe
il est aujourd'hui difficile voire
impossible pour les très petites
entreprises pour les pme ou les pmi
d'être compétitif
elles sont découragés de se développer
et donc de créer des emplois il est si
difficile pour les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
d'entreprendre chez nous alors que vous
en avez envie
alors qu'ils en ont tous envie mais
qu'ils se trouvent obligés de partir
vers d'autres destinations pour pouvoir
simplement se lancer et bien souvent
réussir on parlait de l'acrylique en
valais il ya quelques jours dans tous
les journaux
comment se fait-il que nous n'ayons pas
une silicon valley en france alors que
nous avons tant de talents tant de
recherche que nous avons été du temps du
général de gaulle à la pointe de toutes
les grandes créations qu'il s'agisse
d'ariane qu'il s'agisse du tgv qu'il
s'agisse du nucléaire qu'il s'agisse du
rafale d'ailleurs qui avait commencé à
cette époque
alors oui nous avons besoin de pouvoir
libérer ces énergies qui sont celles des
jeunes de leur permettent de travailler
chez nous et pas systématiquement à
l'extérieur quand ils veulent réussir
sans emploi sans entreprise contre et
compétitive
soyons conscients il faut que tous les
français soient conscients il n'y a pas
d'avancée sociale réelle
le gaullisme c'est la solidarité le
gaullisme ce sont les grandes avancées
sociales
mais ces avancées sociales il faut les
payer
faire des annonces ou des promesses sans
les financer c'est la spécialité de la
gauche parce que n'est ce pas ça ne
coûte rien c'est l'état qui paiera les
tables nous avons trop souvent peut-être
oublié de rappeler à la gauche mais
aussi aux français dans un souci de
vérité que les plus grandes avancées
sociales
la protection sociale l'assurance
maladie nous le devons à l'action
publique
des hommes et des femmes issus de nos
rangs
alors oui il faut une vraie solidarité
surtout dans le monde actuel mais il
faut aussi une justice dans l'effort
nous refusons de fermer les yeux sur les
abus qui menace les droits de ceux qui
ont vraiment besoin de solidarité
nous refusons la politique qui consiste
à faire demeurer dans l'assistanat
ceux qui ont eu un accident de parcours
ou une embûche de la vie mais ans qui
ensuite peuvent retrouver leur dignité
dans le travail
c'est une différence majeure avec les
socialistes
la sécurité c'est aussi nous le savons
bien celle que les français sont en
droit de ressentir celle qu'ils aspirent
à ressentir quand ils épargnent pour se
loger pour constituer un patrimoine
même petit qu'ils pourront tranquille
pourront transmettre à leurs enfants
aujourd'hui il y a trop d'incertitudes
fiscale il y a trop de menaces qui
pèsent sur les parcs et les gens se
disent à quoi bon épargnée finalement on
va peut-être nous le prendre nous nous
privons aujourd'hui sans être certain de
garder quelque chose pour demain
oui chers amis je crois que toute cette
impression d'incertitude d'insécurité
pèsent sur le moral des français pèse
sur l'état de la france
et elles doivent être aujourd'hui au
coeur des débats alors oui je vous le
dis au cours de toute cette année qui
commence aujourd'hui avec vos
universités abordons ces sujets sans
complaisance sans chercher des
propositions à l'eau tiède pour
complaire aux seins ne pas déplaire aux
autres oui il est dans nos de notre
devoir de proposer aux français une
france plus sûre sur dans tous les
domaines
la droite républicaine et le centre ont
toujours eu l'image d'être de bon
gestionnaire
ce sont des qualités qui leur sont
reconnus tant au niveau local qu'au
niveau national
eh bien les élections régionales vont
être l'occasion de le rappeler
et de souligner aussi que la bonne
gestion c'est sûrement pas la
caractéristique des socialistes et du
gouvernement actuel
nous nous voulons encourager ceux qui
veulent se battre ceux qui veulent
démontrer que l'effort peut réellement
être générateur d'un redémarrage et de
vrais succès nous refusions de montrer
du doigt ceux qui agissent ceux qui
réussissent ce qu'ils entreprennent ce
qui crée de la richesse pour tous notre
pays
arrêtons comme françois hollande de 10
et de dire je n'aime pas les riches
le problème n'est pas d'être riche le
problème c'est de créer de la richesse
dans tout le monde profitera
alors dans tout ça est bien dans tout ça
vous avez les uns et les autres une
grande responsabilité
vous êtes jeunes une chance
moi je vous le dit ne soyez pas de pâles
copies de vos aînés rejeté tous les
coller tous les copier coller on
n'incarne pas la modernité avec la seule
l'utilisation de photoshop c'est à vous
de chercher des idées des propositions
nouvelles qui soit adaptée à notre temps
même si ça doit briser un certain nombre
de tabous votre rôle c'est ça vous
n'êtes pas engagé en politique pour rien
vous n'êtes pas des républicains pour
rien vous êtes là parce que vous avez
envie de faire des choses ne vous soyez
ne vous sentez pas contraint par quelque
chose soyez à l'écouté des français
soyez à l'écouté de la france et à
partir de là sur des bases sérieuses et
de bon sens construisez des choses et y
ait des idées aux avancées vous êtes une
force de proposition nous avons besoin
de vous nous tous nous travaillons nous
faisons des choses mais nous devons nous
voulons être aussi à l'écouté de ce que
sont vos inspirations
c'est vous qui êtes une force de
proposition désormais c'est vous qui
êtes aussi les véritables vecteurs de
l'opinion c'est vous qui êtes les plus
opiniâtres sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est vous qui santé est souvent avec un
coup d'avancé
la direction qu'il faut prendre alors
soyez libres c'est ce que je suis venu
vous dire cette année encore sentez vous
libre de penser et d'agir
soyez libres dans vos opinions refusé
d'être embrigadés dans quelques coups
dans quelques écuries de courses de
trotteurs dont on ne sait même pas
aujourd'hui s'ils seront toutes en
capacité d'être au départ c'est pas ça
le problème
le problème c'est que vous vous exprimer
le problème c'est que vous construisiez
sept fons et ce monde de demain dont
nous avons besoin nous ne le ferons
qu'avec vous alors vous je vous le
demande je vous le dis je vous le
conseille cas et dire je vous le redonne
vous les jeunes républicains soyez vous
même soyez vous-même pour construire
l'avenir
soyez vous même pour construire le monde
soyez vous même pour permettre un autre
pays d'être toujours ce qu'il a été ce
pays que l'on aime ce pays que l'on
respecte dans le monde entier
ce pays qui peut conduire vers les plus
grandes aspirations et les plus grands
idéaux
soyez vous mêmes ce qu'ils
construisaient la france